très souvent ces compétences en fait
n'existe pas dans la sphère publique
dans toute la sphère publique il y a
aussi des éléments des complémentarités
qu'on appelle la délégation de service
public c'est pas nouveau ça existe même
dans les traités européens
c'est tout à fait autorisé heureusement
du mercy et les consultants ne sont pas
que des des individus qui voilà qui
ferait doublon et qui viendrait
uniquement pour facturer très cher il ya
un service qui est produit il y à des
processus
il y à des systèmes d'information il y a
des ressources humaines il y as tout
cela à mettre en ordre de marche
c'est quelque chose de très agendée ce
sont des compétences extrêmement pointus
les grands cabinets les moyens cabinets
les plus petits cabinets les on est donc
tout simplement c'est ce qu'on appelle
de la complémentarité économique
c'est pas parce qu'une entreprise privée
intervient que l'argent va forcément de
l'état vers l'entreprise privée il peut
y avoir des modes de financement des
fonds internationaux
l'intervention des banques centrales
bref il ya un certain nombre de choses
qui est que je voulais dire qu'ils font
qu'on peut peut-être rendre plus et x ce
modèle là on a quand même des les
compétences de très haut niveau
notamment dans l'administration
française
je ne dis pas que c'est partout comme
cela dans le monde entier puisque des
casiers comme mckinsey sont présents sur
tout le territoire mondial bien entendu
mais en tout cas en france c'est vrai
que les compétences nous les avons
surtout que souvent les consultants de
chez mckinsey on les retrouve après
finalement dans les gouvernements ou à
l'élysée eux-mêmes dont vous voyez une
sorte de passage aussi ce qu'on appelle
généralement un peu pantouflage entre le
public et le privé
donc on pourrait se dire finalement en
termes de compétences qu'est ce qu'on va
chercher puisque de toute façon parfois
ses compétences à sont à l'intérieur
même de l'état donc ça n'a aucun intérêt
d'aller les chercher ailleurs
donc on peut se poser la question et
puis on peut y répondre en disant qu'il
ya peut-être là une sorte n'a finalement
de convergence d'intérêts d'endogamie
des élites qui joue aussi entre elles à
se passer la balle et à se passer
beaucoup de millions d'euros évidemment
et de dollars quand si quand ça concerne
les états unis donc voilà parce que
pourquoi finalement la question se pose
vraiment alors ça c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons tout le temps à
savoir si ce sont les métiers de demain
c'était il ya effectivement à travers
l'arrivée des nouvelles technologies des
robots de l'intelligence artificielle
il y a au contraire des cabinets et des
cabinets de conseil et c'est de
s'adapter toujours à ce monde de demain
ce marché du travail de demain je serai
pas étonné qu'il y ait également sur
dans certains domaines
hier même chemin se faisait il ya
vendredi dernier donc une conférence sur
sur les métiers de demain il y avait
énormément de cartes de cruciaux nerfs
et on travaillait sur le fonctionnaire
4.0 je serais pas étonné qu'il y ait
aussi des collaborations entre la sphère
privée et la sphère publique sur ces
questions là parce que les innovations
malheureusement les mains du secteur
privé principalement est bon voilà donc
je sais ce que je verrai sur les dix
prochaines années c'est plus une
administration l'administration du futur
sans vouloir faire de de science fiction
avec beaucoup de projets qui sont de
moins en moins dans la hiérarchie mais
de plus en plus dans l'agilité voilà il
ya beaucoup de questions à l'éducation
bien évidemment avec l'apparition des
noues 10 pouces et l'intelligence
artificielle aussi pour votre
information
je suis moi-même un professeur dans une
grande école qui est j'ai passé aussi
mon doctorat sur cette question-là la
science po paris est donc la grande
école s'appelle eileen city et une
sommes en train de travailler dans un
écosystème et l'écosystème de demain il
est composé il est multi composites
à terme je trouverais intéressant aussi
qu'il est peut-être trois parties dans
ces histoires c'est à dire des cabines
et pourquoi pas qui ont leur vision qui
n'est pas neutre
peut-être aussi des poux de chercheurs
qui sont finalement assez peu consultées
et qui sont souvent donc quelque chose
peut-être de plus complexes qui ne sont
pas toujours capables de parler via des
powerpoint très rapidement comme salle
de manière simplifiée et puis évidemment
l'état l'état mais l'état qui doit
peut-être gardé la manette
alors quand on dit que l'état n'est pas
à gilles souvent en fait on veut
finalement lui couper un peu la tête
on veut lui dire dépêche-toi finalement
perdre ton pouvoir et laisse nous les
mains finalement à la laisse nous les la
balle et laisse nous finalement le le
pouvoir d'être à la manoeuvre
donc bien sûr qu'il va y avoir
certainement à un fonctionnaire de
demain et d'après demain mais
aujourd'hui on le voit et on le voit
dans les élections qui concernent des
bols saône à rodez train fou d'emma cran
on le voit très bien l'impact absolument
délirant justement des données des bases
de données des cons brige analytique a
justement des cabinets de conseils du
marketing politique de la communication
toute puissante donc bien sûr on peut se
projeter à 10 20 ans n'a 10 20 ans peut
se dire est-ce que c'est pas finalement
google et amazon qui vont remplacer les
états et finalement est-ce que c'est pas
au contraire de ce qu'on pouvait dire
avec un certains historiens la fin de
l'histoire mais est-ce qu'on n'insiste
pas là à la fin du politique avec un
grand p
et c'est peut-être ça l'inquiétude que
nous pouvons avoir aussi